there have been lots of warnings during
our stretch of brutal high heat stay
hydrated stay out of the sun
and do not leave pets outside or in cars
thank you for joining us at six o'clock
i'm brian loftis and i'm denise valdez
for those that don't listen to those
warnings metro police
showed what they will do to protect pets
that is video you're looking at a police
breaking a window to rescue a dog now
the owner was arrested
and you'll be shocked by this it was the
second time
involving that dog in less than two
weeks left in a car
victoria saha reached out to the woman
who was still sitting in jail tonight
and victoria she tells you she doesn't
deserve to be behind bars how come
yeah well brian denise 25 year old
alexandra evans was
crying when speaking with me she says
she didn't mean to leave her
one-year-old dog named rio in the car
she didn't think leaving him locked up
for a short time would hurt
minutes
[Music]
so tonight she doesn't think she should
be kept in jail the first incident
happened at the end of june
evans claims she went outside and found
her car window broken into a ticket
and she located rio at the animal
foundation on july 6.
a few days later on july 9 officers
rescued rio again
in the same car evans says rio is her
service animal and usually takes him
everywhere
but she left him in the car because he
was just neutered
evans kept telling me it was only five
minutes but according to arrester report
she told police it was 10 minutes
police also report it was 113 degrees
inside the car after rescuing rio
tonight evans claims she does not know
where rio is and
she says she learned her lesson she is
being held on a three thousand dollar
bail
and is expected to be in court later
this month now evans has some run-ins
with the law before
a dui conviction in 2020 and a drug
possession case in 2019.
reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now